[Música]
con nuestro segundo invitado al día
vamos a hablar de lo que ocurre con la
oposición venezolana recientemente la
asamblea opositora de Venezuela votó en
contra de que Juan guaidó el líder
opositor venezolano siguiera al mando de
esta asamblea quitándole entonces pues
el título también de lo que algunos se
lo consideraban como el presidente
interino de esa nación o caribeña ahora
pues la que preside esta asamblea
nacional opositora es Dinora figuera
nosotros vamos a saludar entonces a
nuestro segundo invitado el día para
saber cuál va a ser el futuro de la
oposición venezolana y cuál es la
táctica que están jugando en este
momento para pues tratar de
contrarrestar no el gobierno de Nicolás
maduro saludamos a Luis florido
coordinador de la comisión Internacional
de la plataforma unitaria diputada 2015
también votó en contra de este gobierno
interino de Juan guaidó Luis Gracias por
estar con nosotros esta mañana miércoles
en directo América de France 24 y qué es
lo que está ocurriendo en este momento
con la oposición venezolana porque este
voto en contra de Juan guaidó
Buenos días en primer lugar
y escuchando Mira nosotros no es que
votamos en contra Yo creo que es una es
una visión que reduce mucho lo que fue
el objetivo de las tres organizaciones
políticas más importantes de la asamblea
nacional que decidimos darle un giro a
la política el gobierno interino en una
primera instancia se definió en el año
2019 con la tarea de lograr elecciones
libres justas y verificables eso no ha
sido posible hasta la fecha cuatro años
después en este momento se está
intentando a través de otro mecanismo
por la asamblea nacional Cuál era el
objetivo del gobierno interino eso
también está el tema de la protección de
los activos que se garantiza con la
actual asamblea nacional que además está
encabezada por tres distinguidas mujeres
de nuestro parlamento legítimo el único
o el último resquicio de legitimidad que
queda en Venezuela que esta asamblea
nacional y Así definimos esta nueva
política en la que comenzamos a andar
Luis hablabas de un punto también muy
importante y es la protección de estos
activos de Venezuela en el extranjero no
que también un estado manchado sobre
todo en lo que fue digamos el mando de
la posición de Juan guaidó por por actos
de corrupción eh Cómo pueden hacer
ustedes como posición para realmente
protegerlos y que no se sigan pues
conociendo escándalos de corrupción como
lo que hemos visto
Mira yo creo que la transparencia tiene
que ser proceder de toda persona que
está en el sector público en este caso
nosotros a pesar de que no somos cuenta
antes porque somos diputados tenemos que
exigir de que todos los aspectos de la
vida pública se manejen con
transparencia todos no hemos manejado
las organizaciones que han sido
señaladas en este caso monómeros en
Colombia Pero y tiene que investigarse
lo que se tenga que investigar yo parto
del principio de que si usted tiene la
responsabilidad de Designar una junta
directiva también tiene la
responsabilidad de darle seguimiento y
se ha hecho a través de las distintas
comisiones que tiene nuestro parlamento
para buscar que se clarifique lo que en
este caso han sido denuncias que se han
venido registrando sobre esta materia
transparencia tiene que ser además el
propósito principal de esta junta nueva
junta directiva de la legítima asamblea
nacional Luis Cuál es la diferencia de
esta junta directiva de la pasada es
decir evidentemente en un gobierno como
el de Nicolás maduro que pues es difícil
no hacer oposición en un país como
Venezuela Cuál va a ser ahora en la
estrategia de esta nueva asamblea
nacional para poder ir ganando
nuevamente el terreno en la política no
Bueno fíjate la política en este momento
va a estar asignada principalmente por
lo que lo que tiene que ver con nuestra
nueva política que es la de buscar
derrotar a maduro de cara al año 2024 y
por eso la plataforma unitaria va a
tener una preponderancia muy importante
la asamblea nacional va a tener respaldo
de toda la plataforma unitaria yo que
estoy en en ambos escenarios creo que en
los próximos días por ejemplo el todo el
tema de la comisión de primaria que se
ha definido para tener un candidato
unitario candidato único que no solo
confronte a maduro sino que lo derrote
con toda la desigualdad que eso
significa por la hegemonía
comunicacional por la hegemonía a nivel
de recursos y además por el
soslayamiento de los de los Derechos
Humanos A todo nivel eso es una realidad
que nosotros conocemos pero esta
política que nosotros estamos
empujando al día de hoy tiene que ver
con un esfuerzo en el cual queremos que
todos
empujemos la asamblea nacional la
plataforma monetaria y los venezolanos
sabemos que no es fácil sabemos que es
difícil mucho más con todo el ruido que
ha habido alrededor de la política en
Venezuela y de la posibilidad del cambio
pero es una tarea que nos corresponde y
que no podemos desmayar en lograrla y en
convertirla en una realidad el anhelo
del cambio político de los funcionarios
Luis esto sería realmente posible con
las instituciones como lo están ahora en
Venezuela es decir la oposición
venezolana y también los venezolanos
confían en el Consejo Nacional electoral
en este momento también la oposición
tendría pues la tarea de convencer a los
venezolanos en confiar en las
instituciones ustedes ustedes realmente
lo hacen Cómo hacer para que estas
elecciones de 2024 sean realmente
transparentes
Mira tú has dejado en el clavo de de lo
que es en este caso la la inquietud de
todos los venezolanos O sea la la
desconfianza que hay en las
instituciones
yo no voy a pedirle a la gente que tenga
confianza en unas instituciones que no
le han garantizado a los venezolanos
absolutamente nada pero Precisamente es
donde está la lucha que nosotros hemos
venido encabezando yo te doy el ejemplo
que creo que es un muy buen ejemplo para
toda la oposición venezolana lo que
ocurrió en el año 2021 y entre el año
2021 del año 2022 con las elecciones del
estado de barinas el estado de barinas
estaba controlado por la familia Chávez
que al final fueron los que le dieron
soporte a maduro allí la oposición
venezolana ganó la elección el régimen
tardó en reconocer
de que allí ocurrió algo que no les fue
beneficioso y terminaron inhabilitando
al candidato de la oposición y después
inhabilitaron a otro a otro y a otro
hasta que se pudo presentar un candidato
por parte de la oposición y les ganamos
con mayor diferencia La elección es
decir nosotros tenemos que visualizar
que acá el año 2024 va a ser un año de
muchos obstáculos Y son obstáculos que
nosotros tenemos que superar que tenemos
que luchar que no podemos entregarnos y
no podemos dejarle el poder a maduro
porque él va a utilizar todas las
argucias y todo tipo de ardid para
tratar de desconocer la voluntad Popular
de los venezolanos expresada a través
del voto Luis Y es que también hubo un
giro en la política internacional en
cuanto a cómo se manejaban no con el
gobierno de Nicolás maduro un
acercamiento de Estados Unidos también
en la región digamos el ascenso de Petro
a la presidencia de Colombia El
acercamiento al gobierno de maduro Luis
senasolula Silva en Brasil parece que el
gobierno de Francia también Emmanuel
macron con los acercamientos a Nicolás
Maduro parece que ha cambiado no en no
reconocer a Nicolás Maduro a reconocer a
Juan guaidó en su momento como
presidente interino de Venezuela y ahora
sí reconocer al gobierno de maduro
También tienen un gran trabajo en la
comunidad internacional
fíjate yo no yo no veo ese total ese
reconocimiento a maduro lo que hay es un
reconocimiento de que la realidad
quien está en Miraflores quien atiende
el teléfono es maduro eso es una
realidad sin duda Entonces evidentemente
los hechos políticos
terminan haciendo que no solo la región
sino el mundo busque otros mecanismos
para tratar de lograr que Venezuela
vuelva a la democracia como tal que no
está en democracia tenemos que que
decirlo con Claridad ahora fíjate fíjate
el tema no este cuando Petro hizo su
primera visita a Venezuela lo primero
que dijo que Venezuela debe entrar al
sistema interamericano eso es una
garantía democracia por ejemplo decir
Petro llegó a través del voto este
maduro está allí por por otros
mecanismos no no precisamente por un
voto libre lo mismo Lula lo mismo boric
es decir la región que ha girado hacia
la izquierda No necesariamente es una
desventaja para quienes luchamos
sobre las fuerzas y la oposición creo
que más bien pueden influir mucho más en
que en cada uno de esos países ellos
lograron llegar al poder a través del
voto Y eso nos poca cosa y ese modelo
que se ha venido instalando en América
Latina de Acceder al poder a través de
la Democracia es lo que nosotros
queremos para Venezuela seguro que vamos
a tener a unos aliados allí Por supuesto
los aliados de siempre
no podemos
señalar que los Estados Unidos y Europa
han sido ligados de la causa por la
democracia venezolana